كتابك عشر خرافات في غايه الاهميه طرحت في
عشر خرافات واتمنى ايضا يعني اخوانا
المشاهدين العرب ينتبهوا لهذه الخرافات
العشر لانه بدات تقل هذه الامور وبدات
تصدق احيانا في العالم العربي بسبب عمليات
التطبيع الفجه التي تتم دون هدف دون شروط
دون دون اي مصلحه لاي طرف من الاطراف الا
لاسرائيل ما هي الخرافات العاشر الاساسيه
في هذه الروايه الصهيونيه التي قامت عليها
قام عليها الكيان
الاسرائيلي الخرافات الى خرافات الماضي
وخرافات الحاضر وخرافات المستقبل
والمستقبل طيب نبدا
بالماضي في الماضي كانت الخرافه الاولى هي
ان فلسطين كانت ارضا بلا شعب واشرنا لها
في الحلقه الاولى ارض بلا
شعب بالضبط والثانيه هي ان يهود اوروبا
كانوا شعبا بلا ارض هناك الكثير من الادله
على ان اليهود الذين وصلوا الى فلسطين في
اواخر القرن التاس عشر ليسوا من نسل
اليهود الذين عاشوا في العصر الروماني لان
يهود العصر الروماني تحول جزء منهم الى
المسيحيه ثم تحولوا بعد ذلك الى الاسلام
في الواقع على الارجح ان الكثير من
الفلسطينيين هم يهود العصر الروماني ومن
الخرافات القديمه الاخرى ان الفلسطينيين
كانوا يستخدمون الارهاب خلال فتره
الانتداب البريطاني عندما خاضوا صراعا ضد
الاستعمار الب
وسياسته المواليه للصهيونيه على سبيل
المثال ثوره البراق عام 29 والثوره
العربيه عام
1936 الخرافه الاسرائيليه تقول ان هذا كان
بدايه الارهاب وبالطبع فان هذه بدايه
مناهضه الاستعمار فلسطين الان خرافه اخرى
وهناك مجموعه من الخرافات القديمه لقد
تحدثنا بالفعل عن تلك الخرافات المرتبطه
بعام 48 وان حرب 48 كانت حربا بين داوود
الاسرائيلي وجالوت العربي نحن نعلم ان
ميزان القوى لم يكن كذلك وان الفلسطينيين
لم يغادروا فلسطين طواعيه نحن نعلم انهم
تعرضوا للطرد
الجماعي